you know obviously you you go to a
career of creating characters but to
come up with something as quirky as
Captain Jack and work yes yeah the
things how to be so loved and you know
we've seen those pictures of you when
you visit hospitals you visit schools
and that must be just an amazing gift to
be able to to give those people I mean
for me it's the gift you know the good
they're given be the gift because to go
into a place where you know I mean I've
spent time in a Great Ormond Street
where where it was I would I was the
parent when my daughter was ill and it
was I mean it was that I've known
darkness in my life but that was the
darkest period ever you know was when I
was doing Sweeney and I'd always kind of
done these visits but after that the
visits became more and more important
because the kids
bless him you know they're so strong
they're so courageous but the parents
are the ones who are slowly dying and to
be able to bring a smile or a giggle to
these people is uh it means everything
in the world to me you know it's been
far more than me
which way did you know a lot of girls
would be after somebody like Channing
Tatum